the eh-2-zed of isms relativism moral
relativism is the view that what's right
in one culture may be wrong in another
and that there's no way of judging
between the two it's all relative
there's no absolute truth of the matter
different strokes for different folks
and that's okay
imagine a Martian landing on earth she
would see that people behave differently
in different places they've got
different moral rules different social
customs what's right in one location is
wrong in another she might well conclude
that there's no such thing as the right
way to live or the right thing to do for
everyone at all times it's all a matter
of cultural norms so in parts of Spain
bullfighting is seen as a spectacle
whereas in many other countries it's
considered outrageous cruelty try
setting up a bullring in present-day
London for instance if the visiting
Martian could get an overview of the
history of the world she'd see that in
ancient Rome it was fine to have
gladiatorial combat to the death and to
own slaves but that both practices would
be widely frowned upon in present-day
Rome or Amsterdam or us were attending
fights to the death and keeping slaves
was acceptable for the Romans but we'll
be wrong in today's Europe this sort of
relativism has been popular with some
anthropologists who have attempted to
appreciate other cultures from within
understanding sets of interwoven
practices as responses to particular
circumstances and traditions they
recognized that morality is different in
different cultures and they often argue
that it's ethnocentric to impose your
own set of values elsewhere as if you
know best
such non-judgmental relativism might
seem attractive but think about Nazi
Germany there they became socially
acceptable and even required to treat
Jews homosexuals and gypsies as less
than human
this became right they're both legally
and morally a relativist would simply
have to bite the bullet and say that
that was indeed right for Nancy Germany
that's what morality meant there and
that a morality which treats everybody
with equal respect is no better or worse
than the Nazi way of doing things
just different unless you want to
embrace that sort of repugnant
conclusion is probably best to stay
clear of moral relativism some people go
further and say that everything is
relative even truth that what is true at
one time in one place isn't true for
everyone everywhere or that there's no
such thing as objective truth just the
truth according to me we see hints of
this in politics today there is a big
problem with the sort of relativism
though the theory of relativism itself
would have to on its own account be
relative so the theory that truth is
relative couldn't be absolutely true
you
[Music]